less than two weeks away from title 42
going away at the border and count
rolando salinas very concerned the eagle
pass texas mayor kind enough to join us
mayor good to have you back
what happens on that day assuming
there's no extension mayor or no
alternative plan
well what happens uh first of all thank
you for having me what happens is that
we're getting prepared as a city uh to
have thousands of people cross the
border right now what we're doing is
working together
with border patrol with cbp and we've
created a staging area where if we do
have more than likely hundreds hundreds
of thousands of people will be able to
process them quickly out of our
community because eagle pass is a very
small community and we just don't have
the resources
to have thousands of people in our city
so that seems inevitable we've heard
figures you know from 7 300 today per
day it could easily triple or do you
think that's really possible
absolutely i mean and getting together
with uh federal agents it's very likely
and actually they tell me that the intel
says that there's already
hundreds of thousands of people just
waiting for may 10th 23rd uh once title
42 is no longer in effect so that they
can come in so uh we're getting uh ready
for the wars we definitely don't want
anything to happen like it did it to our
neighbors in del rio texas when you had
an influx of over 15 000 haitian
immigrants coming to their community so
uh we want to maintain order
i see i apologize sir are you angry at
the mexicans for not doing more there
had been some concern expressed by some
board officials that mexico is doing
little to alleviate the the pressure
building ahead of this
well you know we've been working i've
been working with the mayor across in
philadelphia mexico as well as the
governor of korea they're doing a good
job what i feel would help us is a
stronger message from the federal
government from our president uh to tell
these people that we're a nation of laws
and that this isn't uh open borders i i
think the message there is what's
failing because these people think that
we are a nation of open borders that's
why you have thousands of people
crossing uh through
our city of eagle past texas you know
it's very sad today we got we got news
that a lady from honduras drowned in the
river of being seven months pregnant so
we're seeing stories like that it's very
sad but i think we need as a country
we need to send a strong message telling
them that we are a nation of laws and we
can't just come in uh
and we gotta make that we got to make
that clear to your point mayor thank you
very much hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now